hello mr. wonderful I have two questions
for you today
number one is about you
did you ever see yourself being a
multi-millionaire or being on a TV show
going through high school college let's
hear from Joseph elbows number two is um
day trading making about four hundred
dollars a day I'm the junior in high
school
and have two let's start looking for
colleges pretty soon to apply to so I
was wondering if I should save up that
money for college to pay off my car to
pay for my college or should I just like
spend it on like for food for myself or
so just save it for college when I'm in
college or out of college okay Joseph
you got a couple of questions in there
and they're interesting was first of all
the one about me no I did not see it
coming and no entrepreneurs that are
really focused on what they love do you
know it's kind of starting the basement
you're focused on your business you're
working twenty five hours a day and one
day you wake up and someone wants to buy
your company for 4.2 billion dollars
yeah it happens but you don't see it
coming you're so focused on the task at
hand you love what you're doing and that
really is what matters at the end of the
day everybody I've ever talked to that's
how that experience is told me the same
thing it wasn't about the money was
about the journey I feel the same way
now the question about the $400 of day
trading first of all to make that a day
is not easy so you're probably pretty
good at it it's giving you some
background and some basis and some sort
of a foundation upon which to become an
investor later but college is coming up
and you got to pick what discipline
you're going to go pursue I would rather
be saving that money so that you can
have as little debt as possible coming
out of college so get that little nest
egg put together keep it in a safe place
a money market account so you're not
risking it to my
and don't go crazy day trading don't use
a lot of leverage in case you blow up
you know day trading is never that easy
I appreciate what you're doing there and
I've done it myself but this thing is
about getting out of college now with as
little debt as possible and get a degree
that's going to help you get a job I
mean I'm not against liberal arts you
know there's always the serendipitous
chance that you'll find a job coming out
of a history degree but usually that
doesn't happen the three that I like the
best our engineering I like engineering
and oh yeah did I mention engineering
pretty well everybody that's in the
engineering class gets a job and it's a
well-paying one starting like 100 grand
or more and you can pay off your debt
like that but anyways I gotta tell you
Joseph I like your questions but I'm
concerned that you really start focusing
on that whole college nest egg making
sure that you do that with as much cash
as you can so you come out with as
little debt as possible and while you're
in college get a job and work she can
pay off more debt I hate that that sucks
[Music]
this is Vasilis hello mr. wonderful my
name is vassilis and I come from the
beautiful island of Saipan
hey love Cyprus I grew up there I went
to the junior school my brother way to
the English school my dad was posted
there with United Nations
what a fantastic Island I still go I
could tell right away when I heard from
the Seeley's there's a Greek Cypriot
great guy wonderful people that see what
he has to say from your perspective and
your experience what do you think is the
number one factor for success for any
entrepreneur thank you for your response
a fantastic question what is the number
one attribute of successful entrepreneur
I'll tell you what I think it is
[Music]
all right I need a little musical
interlude to gather my thoughts but I'll
tell you what it is a mentor taught me
this years and years ago when you're an
entrepreneur there's so much noise
coming at you there's so much
distracting you and you're trying to
make everybody happy and you try to
solve problems for everybody that works
for you and the customers that you have
and it's so powerful that sometimes you
lose focus sometimes you forget why
you're there you have to set goals both
short and long-term and stay myopically
focused on achieving those you have to
shut out the noise you have to shut out
the criticism you have to shut out the
haters the guys that are hassling you
the people are calling you your
competitors all that stuff and you're
gonna have all that you're gonna have
all of that stuff and that's all
distracting if you have the ability to
just shut that out of your head
you'll be successful because you stay
focused on the prize people are very
very challenging to work with sometimes
you're gonna find that out it doesn't
mean you can't work with them but if
you're trying to make everybody happy
you will make everybody unhappy
eventually because you can't do it you
have to think about three things your
customers you're taking care of them to
your employees you're taking care of
them and number three your shareholders
are the people that loan your money run
your business they are what you spend
your time on 24/7 you can't solve all
the world's problems you can't take care
of every baby whale you can't clean up
all the oceans overnight you have to
stay focused on your business to make
that successful then after you've become
successful and hopefully you will you
can start focusing on all the other
things that are really important to you
but if you try and do that at the
beginning before you solve for your
customers your employees and your
shareholders you're gonna fail and
that's what many many unlock pitchers
are cheaters don't understand you've got
to have a myopic focus to shut out that
noise I know it's not easy to do that
making people unhappy with you because
you're so raised or focused
can often feel troubling to you but if
you can't do that you're not a leader if
you can't do that you will not be a
successful entrepreneur if you can't
focus you just won't make it so remember
that these are tough love suggestions
all right it's just the nature of how it
works
but if you can and you ask me what makes
it much more successful myopic focus on
the long-term and short-term goals and
not letting anything else distract them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hard Sandhu here let's listen to his
question I mr. wonderful my name is parm
sandy from thank you for Canada and I
have a bit of a different take I don't
know that I actually see myself as an
entrepreneur currently I'm more
interested in pursuing a career in
consulting however I'm a little worried
that consulting especially at the mid
tier firms like Deloitte or PwC might be
a dying breed what are your thoughts on
this okay fun let me tell you about
consulting now first of all consulting
is never going to be a dying breed it's
always going to be around and PwC is not
really me if you're talking McKinsey &
Company or Bain Capital PwC they're all
in the same ilk what you gotta
understand is you're gonna be top of
your class to get into these places
because you're competing with you know a
lot of people with perfect scores you
have to be a strategic thinker alright
and you have to want to work basically a
hundred hours a week because they weed
out they call the word after 24 months
and they want to get rid of the ones
that aren't the true strategic
consultants so just letting you know
it's a tough tough job I work with a lot
of consultants I have in the past I
still work with them today but it's I'll
tell you why it's interesting if you
almost sound like you might have the
right temperament for it I can tell by
just what people speak but for me
Consulting is a really fantastic way to
go visit a whole bunch of different
companies a whole bunch of different
sectors a whole bunch of different
opportunities and what the majority of
the the class that's sort of into the 36
month doer not a lot of them will say
out is they jump off the consulting boat
and they land in one of these companies
that they were consulting with and they
become partners in the other or they
become part of the startup or they
become part of the team and they take
their career in a new direction with
one company that they found because they
were in the consulting platform I think
that's a very very cool idea and I'll
tell you why it reminds me of the
apprenticeship programs that the Swiss
of a Swedish on the Danish run well you
basically get steeped into a company
culture and in this case through doing
all this consulting and learning how
hard it is to do that learning about all
the metrics of what running what makes a
consumer company work or whatever
company or consulting line and then with
all that expertise you jump off and you
land in there so I'm cool with it I am
ok with it and I don't care which firm
you work with I mean they don't they
don't waste you they're gonna build you
out so PwC's global know all these terms
are talking about but if you're gonna
become a consultant interview three of
them try and get offers from two but all
the empty package is the same but I'm
telling you my friend you better get
ready to work your ass there's no other
way to put it I mean we would just sit
back you know chopping it up reminiscing
about the good old days and not if you
don't track of my roots where I came
from
[Music]
but like I say man always city it's not
about the destination
it's all about the journey ain't nothing
change with the weather the dangling
carrot it hang from the river your
dreams in the past ain't no where did
you backseat drivers got nothing but
uses shotgun riders to buy and say y'all
liars
I should get a cave forever and I'm too
tired but I'm never giving up this one
kind of hit my role-model like it and I
got a plan